(Ich weiss vorher nie,
wohin es mich führt.)
(Einmal landete ich
auf dem Friedhof.)
(Einmal mit einer südkoreanischen
Reisegruppe im Berner Oberland.)
(Und diese Begegnung ist mir
besonders in Erinnerung geblieben.)
Hallo zusammen.
Kennst du mich? Hoi. Mona.
Ivan.
- Ivan? Ah, Mona.
Hoi.
- Mein Name ist Diogo.
Diogo?
- Ja.- Super.
Und ihr holt mich ab?
Abholen?
- Ja, abholen.
Soll ich mit euch mitkommen?
Okay.
Gut. Gehen wir.
(Ich wusste nicht,
wer sie sind und wohin wir gehen.)
(Für einen Moment
war selbst ich sprachlos.)
Was ist dort, wo wir hingehen?
Dort.
- Dort?
* Er spricht unverständlich. *
Ah, zu ... Okay.
Bist du gehörlos?
Ah, okay.
Aber du kannst Lippen lesen?
Ja.
- Ah, okay. Gut. Super.
(Das war vor eineinhalb Jahren.)
(Ich lebte drei Tage in einer WG
mit gehörlosen Teenagern.)
Ah.
Musst du jetzt in die Schule?
Jetzt dann in die Schule?
Du? In die Schule?
(Am Anfang konnten wir uns
kaum verständigen.)
Es ist ... ähm ... eine ruhige Welt.
Ich werde an den Anschlag kommen.
Es ist wie eine Fremdsprache,
ich verstehe nichts.
(Drei Tage später
waren wir schon viel vertrauter.)
(Seither fragte ich mich oft,
was aus ihnen geworden ist.)
(Aus Xenia, die auf ihre Bewerbungen
nur Absagen bekam.)
(Heute hat sie
eine Lehrstelle als Gärtnerin.)
Um 20.30 Uhr kannst du schlafen?
- Ja.
Ja? Sicher?
- Ich liebe schlafen.
(Der ruhige Diogo,
der genauso gerne schläft wie ich.)
(Ihn treffe ich wieder -
in einer Fahrradwerkstatt.)
* Jazzige Klänge *
(Ivan hat das Praktikum im Käseladen
etwas gestunken.)
(Er wollte Elektriker werden.)
(Sein Glück hat er nun
als Schreiner gefunden -
und mit seiner Freundin.)
(Und schliesslich
ihr Lehrer Emanuel,
der mir seine Frau Patricia
vorgestellt hatte.)
(Das gehörlose Paar
erwartete das zweite Kind.)
(Jetzt sind sie bald zu fünft und
wollen ins Bündnerland umziehen.)
* Jazzige Klänge *
(Wie schaffen
gehörlose, junge Menschen
den Sprung in die Berufswelt
und wovon träumen sie?)
(Zusammen finden wir es heraus.
Das ist "Mona mittendrin - Update".)
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
(Ich bin in Zürich, unterwegs
an die Berufsschule für Lernende
mit Hör-
und Kommunikationsbehinderung.)
(Ich wusste nicht einmal,
dass es die gibt.)
(Es ist die einzige Berufsschule
dieser Art in der Deutschschweiz.)
(Hier treffe ich Ivan.)
(Wir haben uns eineinhalb Jahre
nicht mehr gesehen.)
(Er ist jetzt 17.)
Da ist Ivan. Hey, hoi!
Hallo!
Ich freue mich.
Wie geht es dir?
Gut.
Gut? Super.
- Und dir?
Mir geht es auch sehr gut.
Du gehst hier
in die Berufsschule.
Und das ist?
Laura.
- Das ist Laura. Ich bin Mona.
Ich bin Laura.
- Das freut mich sehr.
Deine Freundin?
- Ja.- Okay.
Seit wann seid ihr zusammen?
- Seit dem 17. August.
Ja.
- Also noch nicht so lange.
Ja, aber ...
Und, ähm ...
Wenn ihr zusammen sprecht,
gebärdet ihr?
Gebärden.
- Gebärden.
Bist du auch gehörlos?
- Schwerhörig.
Ich kann durch meine Familie
gebärden.- Okay. Ah, wow.
Und deine Familie? Die ist?
Gehörlos?
- Mmh.
Okay.
- Genau.
Wie habt ihr euch ...
Kannst du für ihn übersetzen?
Kannst du mir helfen?
Wie habt ihr euch kennengelernt?
Schon lange her.
* Unverständlich *
Sommerlager.
Ah, im Sommerlager.
Okay.
2009.
Dann hat sich alles entwickelt.
Wir hatten lange
keinen Kontakt mehr.
Bis 2019.
Dann kam die Street Parade.
Dort sind wir zusammen gekommen.
An der Street Parade.
- Genau.
Was heisst ...
Was heisst Street Parade
in der Gebärdensprache?
Das wüsste ich gerne. Gibt es das?
Tanzparade.
Okay.
(Dank der Gebärdenübersetzung
von Laura
kann ich mich mit Ivan unterhalten.)
(Ivan kam als Kind
aus Argentinien in die Schweiz.)
(Die deutsche Lautsprache
ist ihm doppelt fremd.)
(Vor anderthalb Jahren machten wir
beim Küchendienst in der WG
die ersten Verständigungsversuche.)
Du ... früher ... dein Beruf?
Mein Beruf? Mein Beruf ist das hier.
Ich bin Moderatorin im Fernsehen.
Ich spreche.
Die ganze Zeit.
Ein seltsamer Beruf für euch.
Und ich mache ...
Ich mache auch Radio.
Das ist noch schwieriger. Ähm ...
Wie sagt man Radio? Ähm ...
Äh ... Diogo ...
Wa ... Äh ...
Es ist schwierig.
Auch sprechen, aber im Radio.
Radio. Ja.
Wir haben uns nicht verstanden,
aber ja.
* Unverständliche Worte *
(Für die gehörlosen Jugendlichen
gibt es im Schulhaus Hans Asper
eine spezielle Sekundarschule,
die SEK3.
* Schulglocke *
(Hier habe ich dank Lehrer
Emanuel Nay erste Gebärden gelernt.)
(Frau) Also. Alle, die hier
anwesend sind, haben Gebärdennamen.
Und warum ist das so?
Bei den Gehörlosen ist das gleich
wie bei den Indianern.
Man beobachtet den Menschen,
schaut, was zu ihm passt,
und gibt ihm einen Gebärdennamen.
Mein Gebärdenname ist ...
Emanuel.
Früher hatte ich
so einen Wusch Haare.
Ihr seht, dass Mona hier ist.
Sie hat keinen Gebärdennamen.
Die Schüler wehren sich.
Sie sagen: "Wir haben
schon einen Namen, der passt."
Ihr seid schnell.
- Mein Gebärdenname. Achtung!
Das ging schnell.
- Also, erzählt mal!
In der WG
haben wir uns Gedanken gemacht.
Bei Mona sind ihre Augen
das Auffälligste. Die strahlen.
Und darum wollen wir dir
diesen Namen geben.
Oh. Danke. Vielen Dank.
(Mona und Dolmetscherin)
Mein Name ...
Und dann gebärdest du deinen Namen.
Also.
- Mein Name: Mona.
Name: Mona.
Genau. Bravo.
- Ah, das ist Klatschen?
Das ist der Applaus, ja.
Das ist ... ja.
Klatschen hört ja niemand.
Und bei dir, Xenia?
Ah, wegen den Locken.
Mein Name ist Ivan. Ich habe mir
immer den Kopf geschlagen,
hatte Beulen und Narben.
Und darum ...
Mit dem I von Ivan ...
Ah, Ivan.
- ... zeigt er sich an die Stirn.
Ja.
(Ich musste mich in
der Gehörlosenwelt zurechtfinden.)
(Ivan lernte,
in einer Welt zurechtzukommen,
in der wir Hörenden
tonangebend sind.)
Guten Morgen.
(Als Vorbereitung aufs Arbeitsleben
arbeitete er in einem Käseladen,
obwohl er Käse nicht mochte.)
Ein bisschen weniger. So, ja.
Ivan, wäre es mit der Kundschaft
schwierig für dich?
Ja.
Und, und ...
Verstehen die Leute von Anfang an,
dass du ein Problem
mit dem Gehör hast,
sonst aber bist
wie alle anderen jungen Leute auch?
Wenn die Hörenden realisieren,
dass ich gehörlos bin,
sagen sie jeweils:
"Ah, du bist taub."
Magst du dieses Wort nicht?
Nein.
(Seither sind anderthalb Jahre
vergangen.)
(Ivan hat in Turbenthal eine
Lehrstelle als Schreiner gefunden.)
(Der Arbeitsweg dauert
von Zürich aus täglich 3 Std.)
(In Turbenthal
ist das Gehörlosendorf,
das spezielle Arbeitsplätze
und auch Wohnraum anbietet.)
(Zum Glück werde ich von einem
Gebärdendolmetscher begleitet.)
(Bei diesem Lärm käme ich
mit Lautsprache ohnehin nicht weit.)
Geht es gut?
Wann musstest du
heute Morgen aufstehen?
Um 5 Uhr.
Um 5 Uhr bin ich aufgestanden.
- Jeden Morgen?
War das am Anfang schwierig?
Im ersten Lehrjahr
war es wirklich streng.
Ich war manchmal krank,
hatte keine Lust, arbeiten zu gehen.
Mit der Zeit habe ich mich
daran gewöhnt und jetzt klappt es.
(Ivan erging es wie vielen, die vom
Schul- ins Arbeitsleben umsteigen.)
(Die langen Arbeitszeiten
und das viele Stehen
waren eine grosse Umstellung.)
(Sein Lehrmeister Claudio
konnte ihn immer wieder motivieren.)
Herz ...
Zusammen ...
Aussen, oben, unten.
(Claudio arbeitet
seit zwölf Jahren im Gehörlosendorf
und kann die Gebärdensprache
schon sehr gut.)
Hast du das Gefühl,
Ivan hätte die Lehre
auch in einem konventionellen
Betrieb machen können?
Hier ist die Lehre
eher auf ihn zugeschnitten.
Hier hat er das Umfeld,
das er braucht.
Er kann mehr profitieren,
wenn er die Ausbildung hier macht.
Es wäre sicher nicht unmöglich.
Es muss ein Arbeitgeber
gefunden werden, der bereit ist,
gewisse Massnahmen zu treffen.
Ich merke, das ist schwierig.
Es ist nicht ganz einfach.
Das ist so.
Er hat sicher bessere Chancen, wenn
er hier eine Ausbildung machen kann.
Ist es realistisch,
dass er irgendwann
auch in irgendeinem Betrieb
arbeiten kann?
Ja, das ist auch sein grosses Ziel.
Er macht auch viel dafür,
dass er das auch machen kann.
Das ist eine Basis,
um anfangen zu können,
auch um mit ihm arbeiten zu können.
Wenn er den Willen zeigt,
klappt das gut.
Was ist dein Ziel?
Irgendwann die
Schreiner-EFZ-Ausbildung zu machen.
Ja, ja.
(Ivan macht hier
eine zweijährige Praktikerlehre.)
(Bald hat er eine Prüfung,
aber noch kein eidg. Zeugnis.)
(Die vierjährige Schreinerlehre EFZ,
die er machen möchte,
wird für Ivan
v.a. wegen der Sprache schwierig.)
Wenn alles super läuft:
Wo bist du in fünf Jahren
und was machst du in fünf Jahren?
In fünf Jahren bin ich
in einem anderen Betrieb,
wo ich in der Nähe wohnen kann.
Ich habe mich schon entschieden,
nächstes Jahr ...
... wenn wir ...
Meine Freundin und ich
wollen in Lenzburg wohnen.
Das ist entschieden.
In Lenzburg, okay.
Einfach in der Mitte?
Genau, weil es in der Mitte ist.
Sie kommt aus Basel, du aus Zürich,
darum Lenzburg.
Eine gemeinsame Wohnung und in
der Nähe eine Arbeitsstelle finden?
Ja, genau so.
Nächsten Januar
werden wir offiziell zusammenziehen.
(So jung und schon
so konkrete Zukunftspläne.)
(Unabhängig zu werden, scheint Ivans
ganz grosses Ziel zu sein.)
(Im Gehörlosendorf
hat es Ausbildungsplätze,
geschützte Arbeitsstellen
und 70 Personen wohnen auch hier.)
(Am Mittag
treffen sich alle im Restaurant.)
(Da begegne ich auch Xenia wieder,
die ich auch aus der WG kenne.)
En Guete!
Danke.
Geht es dir gut?
- Mhm.
(Mann) Es schmeckt gut. Ist das
Chinesisch oder Thailändisch?
(Am Mittagstisch
wird die Gebärdensprache benutzt.)
(Jetzt habe ich ein Handicap.)
(Ohne Dolmetscher
hätte ich keine Chance.)
(In der WG habe ich mit Xenia
die Lautsprache benutzt.)
Xenia,
sprichst du lieber via Dolmetscher
mit mir
oder würdest du ...
Du könntest auch in der Lautsprache
mit mir reden. Ist das peinlich?
Es ist ein bisschen peinlich.
(Bei unserer letzten Begegnung
vor anderthalb Jahren
war Xenia im letzten Schuljahr,
wie Diogo und Ivan.)
(Xenia wuchs
mit hörenden Eltern auf.)
(Sie versteht und spricht, auch dank
einer Hörhilfe, gut Lautsprache.)
Hast du schon eine Lehrstelle?
Ich bin nur schnuppern gegangen.
- Ja.
Aber eine Lehrstelle
habe ich noch nicht.
Hast du ein bisschen Angst,
dass du keine findest?
Ich habe schon ein bisschen Angst.
Aber die Leute sagen immer,
sie hätten keine Zeit.
Aha.
- Sie verschieben es immer.
Das ist ein bisschen mühsam.
- Ja.
Sie geben dir keine Chance.
Aber ...
Ich hoffe, dass es noch klappt
bis zum Sommer.
Was für eine Lehrstelle suchst du?
- Gärtnerei.
Gärtnerei.
Du willst Gärtnerin werden?
- Ja.
(Nach vielen Absagen
klappte es doch noch.)
(In Turbenthal kann Xenia
auf jeden Fall schon einmal
eine Praktikerlehre als Gärtnerin
machen.)
(Zwei Jahre sind schon fast vorbei.)
* Jazzige Musik *
Xenia,
möchtest du Merve erklären,
wie es geht?
Violen ausbrechen.
(In der Lehre hat Xenia eine alte
Schulkollegin wieder getroffen.)
(Merve wird Floristin und hilft
manchmal in der Gärtnerei aus.)
Soll ich auch?
- Hm?
Soll ich auch ausbrechen?
- Ja.
Also, wir müssen
die Blüten ausbrechen.
Wir brauchen kräftige Blätter,
damit es buschiger wird.
- Okay, ja.
Wenn man sie so lässt,
dann werden sie nur hoch.
Ja, okay.
Ihr seid Freundinnen?
- Mhm.
(Dolmetscher) Ja.
Wir kennen uns schon lange.
- Okay.
Manchmal nervt sie mich auch.
* Mona lacht. *
Nicht nur ich, du auch.
Manchmal machen wir
bei der Arbeit Blödsinn.
Dann provozieren wir uns
gegenseitig ein bisschen.
Wenn es langweilig ist
oder wenn die Chefin nicht da ist,
plaudern wir zu viel.
Sagt die Chefin manchmal:
"Schluss mit reden, arbeiten!"
Ja, ja. Das stimmt.
Immer wenn sie sich umdreht
und nicht schaut, gebärden wir.
Wenn sie kommt,
fangen wir wieder an zu arbeiten.
Warum wolltest du eigentlich
immer Gärtnerin werden?
Seit etwa meinem 14. Altersjahr
habe ich mir gewünscht,
Gärtnerin zu sein.
Mein Grossvater
hat einen Privatgarten.
Ich wollte immer helfen.
Eintopfen.
Violen setzen.
- Ja.
Und, ja ...
Jetzt bist du Gärtnerin.
Wie ist es für dich?
- Gut.
Möchtest du hierbleiben
oder möchtest du lieber
an einem anderen Ort arbeiten?
Eigentlich möchte ich
an einem anderen Ort arbeiten.
Das Problem ist,
dass es schwierig ist, zu verstehen.
Ich verstehe schon gut,
aber nicht perfekt.
Du verstehst sehr gut - und trotzdem
ist es schwierig, sagst du. Warum?
Ich bin die Gebärdensprache gewohnt.
Sprechen ist immer ...
(Sogar Xenia,
die so gut Lautsprache redet,
fühlt sich mit Gebärden wohler.)
(Hier, mit ihrer Freundin,
ist sie ein normaler Teenager.)
(Unter lauter Hörenden
fühle sie sich plötzlich fremd
und etwas ausgeschlossen.)
(Chefin) Komm, wir nehmen es
auf den anderen Tisch.
(Unsere Lautsprache bleibt für
viele Gehörlose eine Fremdsprache.)
(Viele haben auch mit
der geschriebenen Sprache Mühe.)
(Das war mir nicht bewusst,
als ich vor anderthalb Jahren in
die Welt der Gehörlosen eintauchte.)
(Als Erstes lernte ich, dass wir
Hochdeutsch sprechen sollten,
eher langsam
und in einfachen Sätzen.)
(Das sagte mir Lehrer Emanuel Nay.)
Wie macht man es im Alltag?
Viele Leute haben keine Ahnung
von Gebärdensprache.
Wenn man
auf einen Gehörlosen trifft,
was soll man machen und was nicht?
Im Alltag
braucht es schon eine Überwindung.
Es braucht ...
Auf der Seite des Gehörlosen
und des Hörenden.
Beide brauchen Überwindung
für einen ersten Schritt.
Wenn man dann einzelne Gebärden
kann, ist es einfach.
Hallo. Wie geht's? Gut.
- Das ist schon gut.
Wie geht's?
Gut.
- Ja.
Hallo.
Wer kommt denn da?
- Das ist meine Frau.
Aha. Ich bin Mona.
Es freut mich. Hallo.
Schön, Sie kennenzulernen.
Und unser Sohn.
- Hey, hallo.
Hey, Aurin.
- Aurin.
Sprichst du auch Gebärdensprache?
Oder ...
Ja. Sie ist zu 100 % gehörlos.
100 %.
- Ja.
Und ist euer Sohn
gehörlos oder hörend?
Hörend.
- Ah, wow. Das ist interessant.
Interessant. Ja.
Na du? Bist du etwas schüchtern?
- Er gebärdet auch.- Ja.
Wir kommunizieren zu Hause
in Gebärdensprache.
Gehen wir!
- Darf ich euch rausbegleiten?
(Was für eine Familie!)
(Patricia kommt aus Ghana,
Emanuel aus Laax.)
(Kennengelernt haben sich die beiden
auf einer Reise durch Westafrika.)
(Sie haben sich verliebt
und geheiratet.)
(Kurz darauf kam Aurin zur Welt.)
* Lockere Musik *
(Inzwischen hat Aurin
ein Brüderchen bekommen.)
(Die Gebärdendolmetscherin
Heidi Stocker begleitet mich
bei meinem Besuch bei Familie Nay.)
Da sind sie.
Hallo!
So schön, dich zu sehen.
Wie geht es dir? Gut? Super.
Hallo, Emanuel.
Schön, euch zu sehen.
Herzlich willkommen.
- Vielen Dank.
Danke schön.
Hey, hoi! Ihr zwei!
Aurin und ...
Larion.
- Larion, okay.
Ich heisse
Au - r - in.
Super!
So gut!
- Das ist Aurin.
(Mona und Dolmetscherin) Aurin.
Als wir uns das letzte Mal
gesehen haben,
war Aurin etwa ein Jahr alt.
Ja, genau.
Der zweite, der damals im Bauch war,
sitzt da auf dem Boden.
Und, Patricia ...
- Das dritte ist im Bauch, genau.
Wow! Ich gratuliere.
Ich gratuliere.
- Danke schön.
Wow!
Ihr habt gesagt:
"Das volle Programm."
Genau, ja.
Sie sind beide hörend?
Oder?
Ja, ja. Genau.
- Okay.
Beide sind hörend.
Für uns spielt es keine Rolle,
ob sie hörend sind oder nicht.
Das Wichtigste ist,
dass sie gesund sind.
Die Lautsprache ...
Wann lernen sie die Lautsprache
und von wem? Auch von euch?
Bringst du sie ihnen bei?
- Nein, ich gebärde mit ihnen.
Es gibt Nachbarn,
die die Lautsprache sprechen.
Sie lernen sie in der Spielgruppe,
beim Tanzen, beim Malen.
Ich habe hörende Geschwister - drei
hörende Schwestern, hörende Neffen.
Mit ihnen können sie
Lautsprache sprechen.
Oh!
Super,
das gefällt mir auch sehr gut!
Ein gelber Klotz.
Was ist das für ein Klotz?
Ein roter?
- Gelb.
Ein gelber, genau.
Es ist auch sehr interessant.
Manchmal muss man auch schimpfen.
Dann schliessen sie einfach die
Augen. Er z.B. will es nicht sehen.
Es ist wie bei den Hörenden,
sie halten sich die Ohren zu.
Er ist ja nicht gehörlos, aber er
hält sich einfach die Augen zu.
Dann muss man manchmal sagen:
"So, mach! Schau mich an!"
Das ist interessant.
Wir Hörenden werden einfach laut.
Wenn wir wütend sind,
werden wir laut und schimpfen.
Wie drückt man das
in Gebärdensprache aus?
Ich halte ihn ein wenig fest und
sage: "Nein, das geht nicht."
Dann wieder loslassen.
Du bist ein Vorbild für mich,
du bist so gelassen.
Ich bin etwas temperamentvoller.
Ich werde beim Gebärden gross,
wenn ich schimpfe.
Das ist wie lauter werden
beim Reden.
Flüstern kann man
mit sehr kleinen Gebärden,
laut werden mit grossen Gebärden.
Manchmal brauche ich die Stimme -
"Stopp jetzt! Fertig!" -
wenn ich wütend bin.
Oh, ja, der ist auch schön.
(Aurin und Larion
ist noch nicht bewusst,
dass sie zweisprachig aufwachsen:
mit Gebärden- und Lautsprache.)
(Mir fällt auf,
wie ruhig es in Nays Wohnung ist -
trotz zwei kleinen Kindern.)
(Aber, nur weil wir nichts hören,
heisst es nicht, dass nichts läuft.)
* Quengeln *
Ihr habt grosse Pläne.
Ihr zieht nach Laax,
wo du aufgewachsen bist.
Genau.
- Wow. Warum?
Erzähl du!
Es ist dein Heimatort.
Mir ist es egal. Erzähl du!
Als Aurin geboren wurde,
habe ich mir Gedanken gemacht,
vorher eigentlich nicht.
Dann machte ich mir Gedanken
über die Zukunft.
Wird unsere Familie langfristig
in Zürich leben oder nicht?
Ich bin in Graubünden aufgewachsen.
Ich habe dort auch eine Identifi-
kation mit der romanischen Sprache.
Ich habe gemerkt,
dass ich wieder zurückgehen möchte.
Wo werdet ihr wohnen?
Wir hatten wirklich grosses Glück.
Wir hatten die Möglichkeit,
ein Haus zu bauen.
Ihr baut selbst?
Oh, wow!
- Ja, wir bauen selbst, genau.
Du kennst das Bündnerland gut,
und Laax ist deine Heimat.
Was denkst du ... für Patricia?
Es ist schon ländlicher.
Wie wird das sein?
* Quengeln *
Wie in Afrika.
Es scheint immer die Sonne.
Hier muss ich es immer aushalten,
weil es so lange kalt
und neblig ist.
Dort ist es wirklich schön,
blauer Himmel, die Sonne scheint,
warm, wohlig, heiss.
Wenn ihr in Laax lebt,
arbeitest du weiter in der SEK3
und an der Berufsschule?
Ja, genau.
Ich werde an vier Tagen arbeiten.
- Ja.
Ich bin ja noch jung.
Man hat das Gefühl,
dass dich nichts erschüttert.
Wo liegt die Grundlage?
Also,
sicher auch dank meiner Familie.
Man sagte mir immer: "Du bist okay."
Man hat mich akzeptiert.
Ich fühlte mich angenommen,
so wie ich bin.
Wäre es anders gewesen, wäre ich
vielleicht auch in Stress geraten.
Aber man war zufrieden mit mir,
und ich war auch zufrieden mit mir.
So konnte ich meinen Optimismus
entwickeln und weitergeben.
Du bist wirklich
ein sehr positiver Mensch.
Jö.
Ja?
Hast du noch Kontakt
mit den Schülern der SEK3?
Mit Ivan habe ich noch Kontakt,
mit Xenia und ein paar anderen.
Auch mit Anja und anderen Schülern.
Weisst du, was Diogo macht?
Ich glaube, er arbeitet als
Fahrradmechaniker. Stimmt das?
Er arbeitet als Fahrradmechaniker.
* Lockere, jazzige Musik *
(Auch mein dritter Mitbewohner
aus der Gehörlosen-WG
hat also
einen Ausbildungsplatz gefunden.)
(Mitten in der Stadt Zürich arbeitet
Diogo als Fahrradmechaniker.)
(Im Gegensatz zu Ivan und Xenia
muss er seinen Weg ins Berufsleben
unter lauter Hörenden finden.)
Hoi.- Mona.
- Philipp.- Freut mich.
Willkommen.
Diogo?
Diogo ist gerade an der Arbeit.
Philipp?
- Mhm?
(Diogo) Dieses Licht geht nicht.
(Philipp) Wir müssen herausfinden,
warum.
Dieses Kabel ...
Hast du es richtig angeschlossen?
Hast du das Zeichen gesehen?
(Philipp)
Wir können es kontrollieren.
(Bei Velo Hubertus können auch
Menschen mit speziellen Bedürfnissen
eine Ausbildung machen.)
(Diogo macht
eine zweijährige Praktikerlehre.)
(Im Moment muss er
ein Fahrradlicht reparieren.)
(Die Kommunikation mit seinem Chef
klappt offenbar einwandfrei,
nur das Licht will nicht.)
Dann weisst du,
was plus und was minus ist.
(Als ich vor anderthalb Jahren
in der WG
mit gehörlosen Jugendlichen lebte,
half mir Diogo
beim Lernen der Gebärden.)
(Er trägt, wie viele andere hier,
ein CI - ein Cochlea-Implantat -
das das Hören simuliert.)
Um 20.30 Uhr kannst du schlafen?
Ja.
- Ja? Sicher?
Ich liebe schlafen.
- Ich auch. Schlafen ist das Beste.
Ja.
- Finde ich auch.
Schlafen ist super.
- Ich hasse es, früh aufzustehen.
Schlafen, träumen -
eine Sprachübung.
Achtung: schlafen.
Träumen.
(Jetzt, in der Fahrradwerkstatt,
ist Diogo hellwach.)
(Beim Basteln
ist er in seinem Element.)
War das dein Traum,
Fahrradmechaniker zu werden?
Du machst alles gerne.- Ja.
- Ja.
Spricht Philipp die Gebärdensprache?
Nur Lautsprache.
Ja, okay.
Was ist das?
Kannst du mir das zeigen?
Darf ich es anschauen?
Wie heisst das? Schieberlehre.
Schiebelehre.
- Schiebelehre.
Noch nie gehört. Zeig.
Okay.
Das ist das.
- Ja.
Zu Hause? 3 Std.? Üben, üben, üben.
Ja.
- Aufschreiben.
Übst du mit deinen Eltern
oder mit wem?
Allein? Wow!
Dann bist du stolz,
wenn du es geschafft hast?- Ja.
Cool.
Er hat das von sich aus gemacht.
Wir haben ihm erklärt,
dass es wichtig ist,
in einem Team sagen zu können,
was man braucht,
wenn man Hilfe benötigt.
Welches Werkzeug man braucht,
wenn man nicht weglaufen kann,
oder welches Teilchen etc.
Dazu muss man die Wörter kennen.
Was für ein Lehrling
ist Diogo für dich?
Er ist sehr engagiert
und v.a. sehr motiviert.
Er hat Freude und Spass am Ganzen.
Er ist ordnungsliebend -
was auch für uns von Vorteil ist.
Der Arbeitsplatz
ist schön aufgeräumt.
Man muss es nicht immer sagen.
Das macht es angenehmer.
Welches sind die anderen
Herausforderungen im Beruf?
Kundenkontakt?
Kundenkontakt ist schwierig.
Sehr viele Kunden sind
mit der Situation total überfordert,
wenn sie merken,
dass er sie vielleicht
gar nicht versteht.
Dann ist es ... Man sieht es ihm
oft auch an, wenn er Hilfe sucht.
Dann schaut er sich etwas um.
* Rumpeln *
Wenn wir können,
gehen wir gleich dazu.
Sonst sagt er den Kunden
von sich aus,
dass sie einen Moment warten müssen,
bis der Chef Zeit hat,
weil er nicht so gut hört.
Was bringt ihm die Ausbildung,
die er hier macht,
auf dem Arbeitsmarkt?
Aus meiner Sicht kann er in Ruhe
die Basics lernen, und man sieht,
in welche Richtung es geht.
Ich gehe fest davon aus,
dass er in einer Werkstatt
eine sehr gute Unterstützung
sein wird - wie er es für uns war.
Ah!
Geht schon.
- Jetzt geht es, genau.
(Diogo wird noch viele Lämpchen
zum Leuchten bringen.)
(Auf dem Weg
in die Selbstständigkeit
ist er
einen grossen Schritt weiter.)
(Emanuel hat seinen Platz
schon gefunden
und bewegt sich mit seiner Familie
souverän zwischen den Welten.)
(Xenia hat in Turbenthal eine
alte Freundin wieder getroffen.)
(Und wenn abends in Zürich
die Berufsschule zu Ende ist,
pilgern Ivan und seine Freundinnen
und Freunde an den Hauptbahnhof.)
(Da, unter der grossen Uhr,
trifft sich die gehörlose Jugend
schon seit Jahrzehnten regelmässig.)
(An einem der belebtesten Orte
der Schweiz.)
Hoi, Laura. Hoi, Ivan.
Hoi.
Geht es gut? Alles gut?
- Ja, es ist alles gut.
Trefft ihr euch immer hier?
Ja, meistens hier.
Warum kommst du hierher?
Was findest du cool?
Ja, ich bin halt gehörlos.
Ginge ich gleich nach der Schule
nach Hause, würde mir etwas fehlen.
Hier kann ich mich austauschen,
ich habe meine Kollegen.
Wir können miteinander gebärden.
Ich kann loswerden,
was mich beschäftigt.
Ich kann
mit einem guten Gefühl nach Hause.
In meiner Familie sind alle hörend.
Ich kann nicht immer folgen,
um was es geht.
Das ist wichtig,
wir haben einen Zusammenhalt.
Wir haben Spass miteinander.
Wir arbeiten alle
in der hörenden Welt,
wo immer die Lautsprache ist.
Wenn wir hier am Treffpunkt sind,
finde ich es toll untereinander.
Ich finde es schön, wenn die anderen
sehen, wie wir kommunizieren.
(Sie sind mittendrin
und doch unter sich.)
(Hier tanken sie Selbstbewusstsein,
um kleine und grosse Hürden
zu überwinden
und ihren Platz im Leben zu finden.)
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Andrea Werlen - 2020